hello everybody hello hello welcome to the bonus stream it's
a little bit of a super unexpected gorilla stream as it
really be is it really unexpected when i sort of told you
guys i'm going to do a gorilla stream anyway this is more of
the chill stream uh because like i wanted to mix it up with
the the back-to-back apex streams that we had all of a
sudden so like to make it up to you guys.
I decided to just, like, do a bonus stream today.
Do an extra bonus stream and just hang out with you guys.
Because both Apex streams, they were both, like, collabs.
I didn't get to really interact with you guys.
I didn't get to talk to you guys.
They're, like, uh, fuck around a lot with chat.
Um, because I was, like, super... Well, I was semi-focused.
Like, who are we kidding?
I was not super focused on the tournaments.
Uh...
If you cast...
If you invite a content creator these tournaments you're
never really super focused you're not really okay to be fair
though i'm going to practice more apex though because i
don't want to throw i i don't really i don't really i don't
throw the challenger circuit um to be fair today's
tournament was more about like games that were more fucking
around than actually serious except for the time when Timmy
yelled at me 30 seconds straight to fucking use my cue and
shield and then I did not do that.
That was a little embarrassing.
That was my...
That was my moment there in front of everybody.
Not just to you guys, but to the normies that watched Timmy
as well.
That...
I was truly...
I was the, I totally left a great impression regarding
VTubers to Timmy's audience.
Truly, truly was the most impact I've ever had towards
Timmy's, uh, uh, towards Timmy's, like, first impressions of
me.
Definitely, for sure, for sure.
I hope, I hope he still enjoyed the time we had.
I hope he still enjoyed the time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You paid the price for chicken and rice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Oh, that for chicken and rice guys.
I was off my grooves like, you know, I didn't get to talk
the drop before we start the game Look, I'm gonna make a
hundred fucking excuses because like as anyone that plays
competitive FPS games before You never blame yourself.
You always blame other people and you make a hundred
thousand excuses why you were not the problem in the video
game So this was, I'm gonna blame chicken and rice.
I'm gonna blame.
It messed with my groove.
You know, I didn't get the chance to like get to know drop.
So I have to get to know him while we were playing.
And then I got messed up because we were getting contested.
So I didn't realize they were there.
Anton, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Don't keep burning.
Thank you, the super chat.
And then everything went downhill.
All because of chicken.
and rice every game after that went downhill it broke
everything it fucked with everything all because of chicken
and rice every game after that God fucked with it Mickey
thank you the super chat thank you thank you this is
actually a zero copium moment even if you didn't see that
skin thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Alex, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
Um, but yeah, I'm definitely going to be, uh, practicing
more Apex starting tomorrow because, uh, not only do I have
the, uh, Scars Cup, uh, also, yeah, because I also have the
Scars Cup and it's a little bit more serious because, uh, JP
people do take, like, like, the tournaments I was in today
and yesterday, they were really, like, you know, we were
all, like, fucking around a lot and there was all, like, for
fun games but like the scars cup one is a bit more serious
um they're like there's no like actual there's no like fun
game modes they're all like gotta try you you actually gotta
try guys we we have to try so i mean i do try i did try
today but i could have tried a little more i i I could have
not tried to get to know drops and like have a conversation
with him I could have just played the game instead of having
a conversation with drops But instead I got a little
distracted Try to have a conversation and I died I could
have not had a conversation and just focused I would admit
But I wanted to get away with I wanted to get to know them I
don't want it to be like never see you again
like um anyway um after after the scars cut we also have
challenger circuit with uh wig and tempo and i definitely
need a try for that member thank you for the five get the
ships thank you thank you will thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you um also i have the challenger circuit
too and those people the people we're playing against they
actually scrimmed and for those who don't They actually like
do like practice games They do practice games like you know
almost every day And then there's me I don't think I have to
explain I don't have I don't think I have to explain more
when I say And then there's me So I have to be less of a
content creator And more of like an actual player You know
and so oh yeah Also a really funny thing After the
tournament like Jen Burden DM me on Twitter and like he
followed me back on Twitter and he was like you're so
fucking funny and honestly when like and like he was like
you're so fucking funny I had a great time playing with you
honestly but Australians said that you know and but I think
Australians are really fucking hilarious because like I like
I like groove with their sense of humor and they don't they
don't give a fuck like Australians like Australians say the
wildest things and like honestly if an Australian says
you're you're really funny like I take that as a fucking
compliment and and then I told him I was like I okay also by
the way like uh I know I only released like top 10 of who
won the most money And, like, um, and so, like, so I know
how much money I won, and I won more money than Jen Burden.
I straight up told him, I was like, oh my God, I actually
made more than, because, like, we joked about it when we had
the game, and I was like, I actually made more than you,
this tournament, like, I'm practically a pro player now, and
then Jen Burden was like, wait, no shot.
and zero from dark zero which was fucking funny as hell I
honestly I thought it was so fucking funny I actually made
more than zero and Jen burden um in that tournament yeah so
I was like you know what I take that as a win I I take that
as a fucking win right there man it's all right just
australian things but i had a great time it was honestly um
nice to find i never played it i never played with jen or
timmy or dropped before so like it was definitely an honor
to be able to play with them even though for dropped it was
like literally one minute but like you know it was only for
a minute with drop that's that's all right but like jen and
like And Timmy, definitely, oh yeah, I'll be remembered by
Timmy as a, as a new cast of that wouldn't fucking listen.
The worst, to be fair, to be fair.
He had an actual real team during the other three strikes,
but then he got the same placement as us.
So in the end, no, he wouldn't have improved.
He, like, whatever teammate he got after me, did, It didn't
matter because he didn't even improve his placement.
Like, those two teammates that he had were 100% better than
what, like, like, they were literally pro players.
Like, he literally had another pro player on his team.
And because of that, they still got fifth place.
So what does that say?
What does that say?
I literally play just as well as having another pro player
on his team, except I just don't know the difference between
Condit Q and Shield.
queue and um and newcastle queue queue okay i'm not a
professional player i'm a content creator how the fuck was i
supposed to know he should have said newcastle queue
i was literally waiting for the for the conduit queue the
queue incident i'll never forget it also for those who are
uh uh for those who are new here um if you guys didn't know
i got partnered with gamer subs what does that mean it means
like not only do i get a referral code but i'm gonna have
merch with gamer subs in the future um and we're gonna have
an art contest uh to to decide um what the merch is gonna
look like uh more details on the merch next week so you're
gonna hear more about the merch stuff next week and like
Sorry about the art contest next week and the prize pool is
like $7,000.
So, so there's, we're going to be able, I think we're
picking 10 winners.
We're picking 10 winners and the total prize pool is $7,000.
So I'm very, very, very, very, very, very excited to see all
the entries.
But yeah, huge shout out to gamer subs for sponsoring 5K of
the art contest.
And I'm putting in an extra 2K in there.
uh just because i wanted to be able to pick more artists so
at first it was like uh uh because like i want that the
reason why i sponsored a 2k more like i added my own 2k in
there is because like i wanted to be able to have more
chances to pick artists and stuff and i felt like you know i
feel like there's gonna be a lot of entries i won't be able
to make it possible to be able to you know give you guys um
just be able to you know give artists uh more chances to to
be picked especially it's really good for like resume and
stuff too If you're an artist that wants to put in your
portfolio for, like, design work and stuff like that, like,
if you were able to, if you get chosen, it'd be really good
for your portfolio and stuff.
And you get money, too!
And you get money as well.
So, um, it's like a win-win situation.
Hate that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tell me what, what do these, uh, gamer suppositories do?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, I'm not really good at shilling.
They sent me a $300 package for free of, like, Gamersup
stuff.
So, okay, they go in your mouth, by the way.
You drink them.
It doesn't go anywhere else in any other holes.
You drink these.
It's powder that you put in your drink, and then you put
water.
Also, apparently, the Gamersup's, like, snack bars are
really good.
I haven't had a chance to try it out, but it was in that
package that was sent.
And...
Because, okay, you know why I clarified?
Because he said suppositories.
Like, like, if you don't know what suppositories are, you
have to specify where it's going to.
Anyway, um, anyway, uh, I was recommending flavors earlier
on in the Apex streams.
And I, the current ones, I haven't tried all of them because
it was a lot.
Okay, it was a lot.
But there's, there's the, the two ones I really like so far
is the melon one.
I'm not going to read up the actual names.
because like apparently people were telling me to try the
guacamole one because apparently the guacamole one is
actually really really good but i haven't tried the
guacamole one because of the name the actual name i don't
know the name doesn't really appeal to me
like everyone's like it's legit really good you have to try
that one this was the best flavor but like but the name
though like the name no it's like in the sample pack too
like they i looked at the sample pack because i was i didn't
want to like i was lazy when it comes because like there's
one you know the actual powder stuff where you like you get
a spoon and put it in but like i'm lazy i don't want to
measure so like i've been like using the sample pack that
they gave me as well you know there's like the ones with the
actual uh bins and then there's the sample pack that gave
you that has like you just rip of it contents in there and
then i got i didn't want to get a spoon and measure it so
i've been using the sample pack and in the sample pack they
have the guacamole one and i won't say the full name because
like i can i can't guys i can't i can't i'm like i can't i'm
a coward i can't i'm a coward but anyway um breezy thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you but when is the
review of the guacamole i haven't tried it yet i have i
can't i i literally i've tried every flavor in the sample
pack but that flavor and everyone says it's the best one
they all said it's the best one
why don't you guys okay so what is what a segue but you know
why don't you guys try it out and it's great because you can
use my code because and get 10 off why don't you guys buy
the guacamole one and then you guys try it out and tell me
how that tastes chat oh my god you know what maybe i am
stuff.
Viva, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If I win the art contest can't get my money in Canadian tire
money.
Thank you.
Lord Corosis.
Guacamole.
Say it, Doki.
Say it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zonderman, not very good at Googling.
Can you say the full name and pig Latin for me?
Thank you.
You know what you can do?
You can click on my link and just search up guacamole.
That's all you have to do.
you have to do guys just switch up guacamole okay anyway by
the way one other show thing uh the lunar new year merch is
and pre-order is neck earning next week so make sure you
grab it before it's gone because everything but the but the
red pocket will be gone forever so uh so like um if you guys
want to grab some merch some limited merch make sure you get
the lunar new year merch I'm trying to wait until I send my
first shipment of merch.
I haven't received our first, like, the debut, the old debut
merch yet.
So the reason why there hasn't been any new, anything new in
the store or, like, anything.
I guess, like, other than that, I am planning on one day
releasing voice packs one day.
One day because there's so many things to do.
I'm so behind on so many things.
but like uh the reason why uh there's going to be a little
uh hiatus with merch new merch orders like not new merch
sorry new uh uh merch releases is because I want to be sure
that I've settled with the debut stuff first like I shipped
those out first before like I receive them and ship them out
first before I think of new merch um just because like I
don't want to like have like a bunch of stuff that's been on
hold you know and everybody's like where is our merch we've
we've been buying merch for like three four three to four
drops now where is it and i'm like please i'm still waiting
it on the it's on the fucking ocean it's on a ship and i'm
still waiting because it takes so long to travel on water
it's like i don't wait like two months for the merch to
arrive to me the lie bro oh my god one time okay this is
recently not one time like right now bro okay so like one of
my packages because remember when i said i ordered like 50
at first to prepare because i thought only 50 of you guys
are gonna buy my merch so like i ordered i pre-ordered 50 at
first because i was like how many people are gonna buy my
merch maybe 50 people and it's been stuck in customs and I
have to go to the to the like customs office to like unstuck
it it's so fucked up and then I was like I was like hey can
I like call because they were like the email me and was like
hey um you have your package and like we need you to sign
these forms and like uh do this and then I was like okay
here's my information because they needed one thing and then
they replied back and Never mind, go to their office.
And then to settle all of this.
And then I was like, hey, um, where, what?
First off, where the fuck is this office that I have to go
to?
Like, I was like, what does that mean?
They're like, go to the office.
Like, go to, like, this, the customs office.
And I'm like, where the fuck is?
Where is the customs office?
Where?
And then they were like, I was like, hey, I'm confused.
Um, I've never done this before.
And can you give me this information?
Like, what do I do?
Like, who do I call?
And then they were like, you can't call them.
Go to their office.
And I was like, um, where is the office?
And then they gave me the address.
And then I looked it up.
The worst part was.
I looked it up and they're closed.
They're closed on like Fridays to Mondays because it's a
Canadian hot.
It's Easter.
It's fucking Easter.
So I can't do anything about it.
I was just like, and then like the manufacturer got back to
me and was, because it was like a back to forth with them.
And then I was like freaking out.
And then the manufacturer got back to me and was like, Hey,
what the fuck is going on?
Like, the, like, um, you're supposed to pay the, the custom
taxes by the end of this month.
What's going on?
It was like, by the end of this month?
Bro, it's not, it's Easter.
What do you mean by the end of, it's Easter?
How am I, I can't even call them.
I was just like How do I even call?
They don't even take calls And I was like Because the guy
literally said in the email They don't take calls And I was
just like what do you mean They don't take calls I was just
like I can't even call them I have to be there And then And
then And then I told the manufacturer, I was like, I don't
know what to do.
They don't take calls.
Look at their office hours.
They're closed.
And then they're like, okay, we're going to figure this out.
And they were like, oh, we got you an extension.
We extended it to Monday.
And I was like, Monday?
It's still Easter.
I was just like, what a...
fuck did i suggest monday it's not gonna be open it's still
easter i was just like i was just like bro it's still closed
and and then i was like i replied back and i was like the
office is still closed on monday i don't know what can you
give me Tuesday?
I literally was like, um, can you, can you give me Tuesday?
The office is still closed on Monday because it's Easter.
I was so confused.
I was like, don't worry.
We extended it.
I'm like, to what?
It's still closed.
I can't, I just can't believe.
I'm just like, I know I'm repeating like actually blew my
mind that they were so generous enough to extend it to a
Monday when it's still closed like it was it was so generous
guys they extended it to a date where I still can't visit
the office and I'm like I quit I was just I don't I didn't
know what to do I was just like um I'm like waiting for them
to get back to me on whether or not I mean what else can
they do if they can't do Tuesday I don't know they're not
getting my money I guess like I at that point I don't
fucking know so yeah anyway happy Easter everybody I hope
you guys are having a great
me but i hope you guys are having a better easter than i am
apparently um uh but that was that's basically how's my how
my life is so far um um also like oh my gosh funny thing is
uh all right alan thank you thank you thank you i saw in
your post re-debut your tomato form form with a hat Is that
Tago?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I told you guys before.
My real form.
I still have my hat.
I can put on a hat.
Yeah, I didn't know.
I told you guys about this.
I just don't know where my hat is right now.
I need to ask my creator, the one who birthed me, like, if
they can, like, find my hat, my hat or you know or or find
my hat i actually lost my hat i don't know where it is i
actually don't know where my hat is but yes i i can of
course i can wear a hat it's a fucking hat like what do you
mean you think the hat is glued to my skull i say as i can
take off my hat on my skin suit um this one is this hat is
glued to my just so you guys know this hat is glued to my
skin suit it's like sewed in because like i'm wearing a skin
suit so this one is like glued slash sewed in into my skin
suit but like i have multiple hats i have like a collection
of hats and uh the tome in my real form i can wear that hat
i just don't know where it is that specific hat i don't know
where it is
uh miki thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
hey i have a serious question dragoons what game should i
get my roommates to play as homies as bros as amigos as you
know um as a bro um um apex bro i don't fucking know okay
but like do you want them to be your bro still because you
don't want them to be your bro you should play like any
board game any type of board game like uh like monopoly or
like it takes two which is not a board game
Any type of board game if you don't want them to be your
friend anymore Mario party, exactly Mario party, stuff like
that If you want to still be their friend No play Oh yeah,
if you don't want them to be a friend anymore Also play that
cooking What was that?
Play it up Play it up That ruins relationships That's true
Thank you Thank you for the super chat Thank you Thank you
Not to throw more on your plate But you're still planning on
opening a PO box Also, congrats on the gamer
sub-sponsorship.
GamerNade flavored when.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good question.
So the reason why the PO Box is still not open yet is
because Mr. Mann is opening the PO Box for me.
And he recently moved.
And we were dealing with the PO Box stuff.
And the reason why it's not open yet is because apparently
the PO Box played.
um they require mr man to be on a lease and i don't wait is
it is he doing okay wait um he is legally living somewhere
uh he's just he they're just working on his lease right now
just so you guys know he's not living he's not living
anywhere illegally just so you guys know i didn't realize
when i said that it sounded really bad It sounded really
okay.
Anyway, he is currently because he's like Rooming roommates
with people so he is currently working on his lease at the
moment So the moment he is on the lease he can open the PO
box So do not worry.
He is living somewhere very legal It's just that it takes
time to be on.
I don't know how American.
I hope I didn't fuck him
I don't even know what American living scenarios are But
They're working on it They're working on The moment he's on
the lease We will have the PO box open That is what we're
waiting on at the moment That is what we're working on And
like I asked him I was like how long does the lease take And
I also asked his roommate, because, like, you know, just in
case, just in case, and like, the roommate said it would be
like, it's like, don't worry, everything's going on track.
It would be, it would be done either by the end of the
month, by this month, end of this month, or beginning of the
week for next month.
So, so we're just waiting on that and then the moment he's
on the lease We have our PO box Because you're sending,
remember I'm telling, remember reminding you guys this The
PO box is where Mr. Man lives And like, um, so, or near,
yeah, so it's always I mean, we need his lease Anyway, I was
just like, did I dox Mr. Man?
Well, anyway Um, this is where Mr. Matt is located.
And, um...
And, it's where, it's where he's located.
And because of that, um, you're sending stuff to where he's
located.
And so he can, like, check it.
And then, uh...
box it's a PO box so so basically he is gonna be looking
through the mail by the way we're gonna have like rules and
regulations regarding the PO box so one thing is you can't
send us food you can't send us any liquids or food and then
the other thing is like um we won't be accepting any like I
think um any I don't remember I just remember we any
electronics yeah we won't be accepting any electronics and
also no food and like he's gonna be like screening
everything for me including mail so like your fan mail will
be read by him so like if you're writing me anything make
sure you're okay with him reading it i mean it's not new
okay guys i'm just saying like before times for my fan mail
when you send me fan mail they were also screened so like
It's not like, it's not like I was sent fan mail and, and
like, um, they didn't know what was in it.
It was also screened and read by others as well.
So like, I'm letting you guys know right now that Mr. Matt
will be reading your fan mail and will be looking through
all of the items that you guys are sending me.
So like, just go in there with that mindset if you're
writing anything to me or if you're, me anything yes you can
write him a letter as well chat you can also write him a
letter if you want to just make sure it's addressed to mr.
man and not me okay guys just make sure uh breezy can i send
a copy a shadow a hedgehog for the ps2 well you send me a
ps2 as well where am i gonna play it on what am i like
breezy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
d-drag again thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um oh yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you mr man hiding from the irs under dokeybird on the lease
i think it was super chat thank you thank you um
but yeah that's like that's the current update regarding the
po box we're working on it we're working on it chat i'm
we're trying our best we just have a lot of work to do
We have a staff volunteer to show me around SakuraCon.
So we had like, we actually had like, we had a volunteer to
show me around SakuraCon and grabbing me merch.
So yeah, to all the artists that I met at SakuraCon, thank
you.
Thank you for drawing me and producing like, producing merch
for all the drag.
Goons.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
I'm hoping to do that more so I could be able to be able to
I guess like have more what's the word?
Have more opportunities to visit other artists' alleys
around the world so I won't be like as limited.
So it was a nice experience to try out to see, try like,
what's the character being able to like visit uh a
convention and stuff being able to say hi to the artists and
stuff like that and i was really surprised apparently my
merch was selling really well at artist alley like i think
like two to three artists was telling like for one of the my
merch was sold out it was like one of the only one the only
like keychain or charm that was sold out um on day two
apparently they sold out on day one i was like really really
surprised and then they were telling me that i'm like a best
seller or something i really appreciate it chat i i i really
really appreciate that uh you guys bought like you know you
guys supported the artists as well and um and that you guys
like bought so much merch from me i really really really do
appreciate that uh but yeah uh one of the volunteers like
brought me around on their phone like one of the staff Like
they were like they were boofing at the convention.
It wasn't Sakura Khan staff, but like one of like the booth
staffs, like someone that was doing like these booths or
something as an exhibitor volunteered.
Like Mr. Man connected me to one of the staff that was an
exhibitor.
And they volunteered to like show me around on their phone
and like saying hi to people.
And like, yeah, it was a great, great experience.
a convention well i like it one day be like an actual
convention guest guest so um that's really my dream well not
really dream because like i've had i've already done it
before but not a dream but like i hope one day like as doki
i can um have like meet and greets like official convention
meet and greets and um be able to like as an official
convention guest you know like as a guest at the convention
and uh and be able to meet you guys i really do hope so in
the future uh but yeah that was that was fun that was it was
fun though being able to talk to all the artists and stuff i
still can't believe my stuff sold out i can't believe it i
was so surprised You know, because like I'm not under any
company or anything.
I'm just me.
I'm just I'm just me.
I'm just little old like little dokey like all all little
old indie dokey trying to make it in the no I mean I think I
I've made it before but like you know what I mean just try
trying to survive out there in the indie world
it's always scary it's so scary being indie because you have
to do so much stuff to be like i guess like relevant in the
indie world because you're you you don't have like a company
or brand like under you so then you have to uh you have to
like you know be have a brand to serve that's like able to
survive as a solo like i'm biancé
You can say I'm Beyonce
You did not You did not just call yourself Beyonce No way
Okay I aspire to be Beyonce You're right I'm more like Okay
you're right Um, what's your name?
I'm more like the Spice Girls.
And I'm trying to be...
I'm trying to be Posh Spice right now.
You're right.
I'm more like Posh Spice.
Trying to make it out.
Make it in the world after the Spice Girls.
After you're like...
Beckham then.
Um, oh, I want to be Sporty Spice, but Sporty no, no, I
don't, because nobody remembers Sporty Spice.
What's her name?
What's Sporty Spice's name?
Everyone remembers Posh Spice's name because she married
David Beckham.
But who the fuck is Sporty Spice name?
That's right.
That's fucking right.
None of you But everyone remembers Victoria Beckham Like
You're so Everyone remembers Victoria Beckham No one
remembers fucking Melanie Whatever her name is And everybody
knows Beyonce Everyone knows Beyonce I don't want to be
Melanie No one will remember Melanie They have names was it
I like how someone was like wasn't she like Melanie like as
a question you're not even fucking you're not even like sure
of yourself that's the worst part you're not even sure of
yourself of her name you remember because I literally
googled spice girls I literally googled spice Because I was
like, who were all the Spice Girls?
Like, she was a badass.
You don't even remember her.
You just remember her as a group.
And that is why I am scared.
That is why I am scared.
Um.
Alright, anyway.
Or maybe because...
does Melanie people know Melanie in the UK maybe all right
what what songs has Melanie sang what songs has Melanie
Melanie sang that you guys know that you guys um that you
guys remember that's not spice girl songs
I saw because someone was like I lived in the UK for eight
years and I don't even remember her at all.
Oh my god.
No, I don't want to be Justin Timberlake I don't no, I don't
want to be it Beyonce is like the most safest person out
there.
I don't want to be Justin Timberlake right now.
I don't think anybody wants to be Justin Timberlake at the
moment
She's like the perfect queen right now.
She's literally, she's literally like, like in a perfect
spot at the moment to be a person.
And so, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Names are useless.
We should all be serial numbers.
What the fuck happened?
Are you guys a serial killers?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What happened to Justin Timberlake?
Well, he like...
some stuff happened well there was a book that's all I'll
say there was a book that I want to see Chris thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you um it can if i can be a
testament to the family shells i've been hard at work
100%ing my dokey shrine and i've now purchased over 12 items
from indie vendors uh i'm indeed my wallet hurts worth yeah
but you'll never get a better dokey shrine than me thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you well yeah that is why
that is why i want to be bionce
choice right now or Victoria Beckham because the or Victoria
Beckham because because like everyone remembers Victoria
everyone remembers Beyonce and like Victoria was so funny in
that one documentary where she was like I had it rough and
then David Beckham was like tell them your dad's car tell
them how many cars your dad owned
actually the fun bro david beckham was so real it was so
fucking real for that and be honest be honest what car did
your dad drive do you guys not know that oh my god wait let
me let me send that okay uh uh victoria beckham uh working
oh yeah because she was telling people she's working class
And then David Beckham was like Be honest
Yeah he definitely Yeah he definitely slept on the couch
that night Um Barry thank you for the super chat Thank you
thank you How was the turn?
He had stuff to do I missed it Uh We ever gave when Nico
again The show with him was hilarious Thank you for the
super chat Thank you Oh I think the tournament was really
really fun I definitely enjoyed the tournament a lot But I
definitely will be tryharding more for next week.
So I'll be practicing more Apex because I was like...
I've been slacking with my practice.
Because like...
I had a lot of stuff to do.
Like back to back to back to back.
But I'm getting a lot of things done recently.
And that I was like super like...
That like took up most of my time.
And a lot of the things that took up a lot of my time.
Is like I don't have to deal with it anymore.
So, like, I'll be definitely be practicing more Apex.
Because the next two tournaments are very...
Are very actual try-hards.
Actual... Actual... I have to try now.
I have to actually try.
But, yes.
So, Nico, I'm down to play with him in the future one day.
Just because, like, right now, like, the reason why...
I haven't had really much, like, repeats.
reach out to me because I want to try and interact with as
many new people as possible every week.
I didn't know what would go me because we had a fucking long
ass game to complete.
But in that, I've been trying to reach out to new people
every week to collab with because I want to, like, you know,
get to know more people.
I want to have, like, people to collaborate with in the
future with other games, any multiplayer games and stuff.
So, just slowly meeting more and more new people Every week.
That's my goal.
Every week I want to meet a new person.
This week I met a lot of new people, that's for sure.
But it was great to finally play with Jen.
I do want to say, like, I've always wanted to play with
Timmy.
I've always wanted to play with Jen.
And because they're, like, Apex streamers I've watched, you
know, even back in the day.
I watched, like, Timmy and Jen a lot back in the day.
And so it was nice to be able to play with them.
It was definitely a...
stream come true type deal um because oh my god speaking of
okay this is like a different topic but like um um i
actually had like uh one of my super old friends i haven't
talked to this person in a long long long long time but they
were one of my like friends that first made playing
overwatch uh they used to be like a big overwatch content
creator and like they reached out to me and was like do you
want to try out like do you want to go back to overwatch and
like you know play and i was like first off and like oh yeah
he wanted me to come back to overwatch and try out the face
it and overwatch for those who don't know um overwatch
league is gone now and now they established face it uh which
is like the new overwatch league system i think i think i'm
not sure i don't i don't know i know like face it is like a
csgo thing but they made a face it for overwatch rank
Overwatch rank I don't know they made it face it for
Overwatch and they like message me they like DM me about it
and was like we should do it we're what and I was like I'm
fucking and it I was like bro bro I'm fucking washed I don't
even have Elari or like Lifeweaver unlocked Like, what the
fuck?
I literally said, bro, Lamau.
I'm fucking washed, bro.
What the fuck?
And then they were like, no, man, it'll be fun.
So I haven't responded back after that.
But I'll think about it.
I'll think about it.
There's always, I'm not giving Overwatch has too much of my
money because back then I was a young fool.
Back then, I was young, naive, and I actually spent money on
Overwatch accounts and boxes.
Now, now, now I'm not spending money on Overwatch.
You need to know, I had so many Overwatch, the amount of
money I gave Overwatch in name changes and accounts and loot
boxes was way too many.
I am not fucking buying Elari.
I'm not buying to unlock Elari and Lifeweaver.
I'll fucking play the game and unlock them if I have to.
And it's a hundred games.
You need to play 50 games.
You know what I didn't realize?
Do you know what I didn't fucking realize?
You need to like, to unlock a character.
You have to click on the character.
And then you have to click unlock.
Like, you have to be like, you have to click on the
character and do like, do the challenges.
for that character.
So, because I thought, I thought when you play games, it
automatically registers as like what?
The support character?
I didn't realize you have to click on the hero and to click,
do the challenges for those heroes.
Because I was like, oh man, I did 20 games.
Yay.
And then I clicked on Illari and it said zero out of 50.
I was like Yay I did 20 games Of Overwatch I was like okay I
didn't know it was 20 I was like yay I played a lot of games
of Overwatch I wonder how many games I have left to unlock
Elari I clicked on it Zero out of 50
Zero out of 50 Zero out of fucking 50 I was not happy I was
not fucking happy heels and that clicked on it and then i
saw i saw the number go up i saw the number go up after that
uh plastic thank you for the magenta soup but they could
thank you watch to changing the heroes to be all free no
need to unlock for season 10 if i remember correctly they
give the magenta soup but they get oh my god wait when is
season when is there season it's already season 10 game come
out last year we're ready on season 10 holy fuck we're gonna
run out of fucking cosmetics like what the fuck we're
already at season 10 jesus christ bro i was looking at like
the icons again that's just uh not gonna lie no wonder like
they changed up the reward system Overwatch sponsor me and
then I'll I won't talk like this about Overwatch
I love Overwatch because you guys started my career um
anyway um anyway as I was saying as I was saying as I was
saying um um I was looking at the rewards on on overwatch
and i was so fucking surprised how much if like how much it
felt like the the reward system for top up did you know they
try to make it like okay i was looking at the icons by my
silence yes i was looking at the icons and i was so
surprised okay before i mentioned more before you guys were
like wow doki what a sellout i want you to say i want to say
everything i've said is not as worse as everything actual
Overwatch content creators and actual Overwatch pros have
said about the game.
And they have been sponsored and have been paid to promote
the game much more than me.
They play the game professionally and some of them are like
Overwatch content creators.
And I swear to God, they have said worse things than what
I've said.
Anyway, anyway, um, anyway, as I was saying, as I was
saying, the fucking Overwatch icons, I was so, I was so
fucking surprised.
I was so, I was so surprised because back then, back then in
Overwatch, like, the early top 500 prizes were really good.
like the animated sprays and the and the fucking icons were
really really fucking pretty now like back in overwatch one
it was like now like in the final seasons in overwatch ones
they it was like weapons so like if you don't get if you
don't get top 500 you get like a normal weapon icon like a
like like tracer's weapon it's just tracer's weapon but if
you get top 500 it's gold
it looks terrible it's just the same thing it's just a color
change in the in the early top 500 days it's like a
different scenery of the icon and it actually has the top
500 icon and the top 500 icon is like right in the middle
fucking huge it was right in the middle and then you can
also the jade weapons too oh my god why would i have a jade
weapon when i could have a gold weapon Why do I want my item
to be fucking green?
I'm sorry if your favorite color is green.
I'm so sorry.
What do I want?
A green weapon or a fucking shiny gold?
But, but, but as a member, as a member, it's like amazing.
Green is great though.
members guys please don't unsubscribe please don't remember
guys guys please don't remember every green is amazing in in
members though like but like as a weapon as a fucking just
seeking of members don't worry I have it back up guys I
didn't lose you guys because we're gonna get new member
matches Let's go.
Guys.
New member badges.
No.
No, you can't have member because we're going to have new
member badges.
Woo.
Yes.
Green is a great color.
Woo.
But look at these new member badges.
Guys.
Let's forget what I said before let's forget Let's forget
everything I said before And talk about how great it I mean
I have green eyes chat Thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
Thank you Next see thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you guys.
Look at that.
Oh, you're thinking of the five gifted ships Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god, not gonna lie.
Okay guys Okay, but like you guys are blue on my screen.
So like it's different
Jen Rob thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Green is a very is not yeah, exactly green is not
a very creative color Um, so I mean they give this super
chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Whoa guys look look guys look at the sub badges
Also, like, to be fair, I told I changed the tomato to be
like this.
This was, like, the edit I wanted to make.
So, yeah.
This is giving me the new tomato icon.
Because I wanted all the sub-batches to be, like, universal.
Thank you to the artists that made the first tomato badge.
really appreciate for the placeholder um so like really
thank you uh but i'm gonna be changing the tomato because
like the tomato badge because i want like all the badges to
be universal and stuff so it's gonna look like this after
it's gonna look like this later when it's done um but yeah
actually like um i'm really thankful uh the artist is like
for the badges is one of my really good We've been friends
for like, oh my god, for like 15 plus years, I think.
And we've been friends for like 15 plus years, maybe longer.
Maybe longer, but we've been artists friends.
We met on DeviantArt.
We, the cursed site now.
It has, that site has gone downhill.
I'm surprised it's still around.
I'm sorry, but I'm surprised DeviantArt is still fucking
around.
and DeviantArt and um we've been artist friends for a while
uh when I was in uh when I was like you know when I started
seriously YouTubing like you know the last two years we
actually lost uh lost contact not lost contact but we've um
we never had a chance to talk to each other during those two
years uh because I was so busy and um I was really really
busy and then uh they were busy as well and then uh recently
we started talking again after and they were like yeah like
i didn't really want to bother you like you were so busy
with work and like i was in there like i was very busy with
life as well so like i didn't really want to bother you and
just wanted to watch you grow and then like they reached out
to me after everything and was like uh being like sorry like
never really talked during those two years um and um and
like uh and then i was like oh hey you wanna still like work
for me and you still wanna like draw some stuff for me?
And then they're like, yeah, of course.
Because like we've always like, they've always like done art
for me.
And like we started like our, they're basically the artists
that I opened an Etsy with.
That's my friend.
We've been friends for 15 plus years.
And like I've always helped them with like money issues and
stuff in the past.
so like um i helped them grow their art more and help them
find client like i i was sort of like their agent i was i
was sort of like like their agent slash like manager in a
way that like um i helped because they were very artistic in
what they do they're like an untalented they're like an
incredibly talented artist and i was the one that persuaded
them to do like twitch emotes and do like art stuff and like
open like art stores and stuff like that and like to promote
their art and help them get like clients and stuff for their
twitch emotes and everything and like um and like i was like
you should do emotes with me your art is so good for emotes
and everything um and uh and then like you know and then i
was like do you still want to like we were talking and then
they're like yeah like they're still trying to find like um
they're still trying to like uh figure out like their career
and stuff because uh they're trying to find like a stable
job regarding art and stuff and i asked them i was like you
want to you know do you want you want to do art for me you
know like i can i i i'm looking for an artist for my sub
badges like you want to do them and they're like yeah of
course like i'll always do art for you if you want me to and
i i was like really happy because I always love their art as
well they're very talented artists and yeah so I'm really
happy that they're doing my sub badges I even gave them like
a really big tip because I was like bro I make like way too
much money now like just take it like
like you're my homie man like you're my bro just take the
extra tip
um I'm so excited I'm really really um I'm really really
really excited to catch up with them later too.
I actually had a lot of old friends that reached out to me.
I haven't replied back to their text yet.
But this is an old friend that I basically got in one season
in Overwatch.
I got like top 500 with her.
We would do a support.
We would do a support together in Overwatch 1.
And we got top 500 together.
And like, like she reached out to me and was like, hey,
like, um, we saw everything that's happening, like, like,
I'm sorry we lost contact instead, like, lost, uh, we, I'm
sorry, like, we, we did, like, talk to each other after, um,
after Overwatch and stuff, like, uh, you want to just, like,
you know, hang out and just catch up and everything.
I was like, I haven't responded back, but I thought, like,
it was, I went to, like, BlizzCon with her, too.
That was how long ago it was.
It was so long ago.
Like, she was, like, actually one of my best friends in
Overwatch.
But we lost, like, we lost...
What's that word?
Lost touch?
Is that it?
We lost touch after Overwatch sort of died.
Not die, sort of died.
But, like, after, like, we both...
Like, she had to go, like, to...
She had to, like, focus on studies and stuff.
And then I moved on to Apex.
Like, I lost contact.
Yeah, we lost contact.
But she was, like, actually...
One of my best friends in Overwatch 1.
And, like, it was really nice that she reached out to me and
stuff, too.
So, yeah, I should text her back soon.
I should text her back soon.
It was just really nice, you know.
It was really nice that a lot of my older friends reached
out to me to talk and just, like, wanted to hang out and
stuff.
So, it was really nice.
Yeah, I'm hanging out with my other, like, my other, my
artist friend, the one that his friends lived for 15-plus
years, like, tomorrow, just to catch up.
and everything um well thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you uh contract dokey friend to do monthly
backgrounds for you give her more income is a plus thank you
thank you this is so wholesome love it and so thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you thank you oh my god i had
like old apex friends too like um this one another apex
friend oh my god this apex friend in like i don't know
they're a doctor now but they were in a dentist they were a
dentist they're a doctor they were in med school i'm trying
to remember fuck they were in med school but don't remember
it was dentistry or or or doctor but one or the it's the
same thing they make a lot of money they make not a lot of
money but and then contacted me and um when it uh one then
contacted me too to be like you want to catch up and stuff
and everything um they actually they actually it was really
wholesome they were the ones that like um supported me and
stuff when i you know when i first started seriously
v-tubing and everything uh when i like had my big break
basically and like applying and stuff like that like they
helped out and everything and was there like cheering me on
so like it was uh we lost lost contact when i first started
seriously working just because like um it was very hard i
think like when you when you get become corporate it's very
hard to keep in touch with people um because you're always
so busy and i really appreciate all my old friends like uh
reaching out to me and everything and like being very
understanding that i was just so fucking busy that i was
like i didn't have a chance to like talk much to a lot of my
old friends and everything and um so it's really nice that a
lot of them like reached out and stuff like that like and
was like super understanding with Like, like, we're just me
being like, uh, me being anti-social.
I mean, me being very anti-social and stuff.
So I really, I really appreciate it, appreciate it too.
And yeah.
Uh, Kumi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As a doctor, I can assure you, Doki, no, we don't make a lot
of money.
money really it was all a lie like
Asian parents lie to me why the fuck do they always want you
to be a doctor
it's always doctor or lawyer no way I always thought doctor
lawyer But you don't make a lot of money Oh my god I feel
like The world is just a lie It's just To be fair Like it
must suck to be a doctor in America Because of student loans
I would just say that like It must take you fucking years to
make back The amount of money That it takes to pay off Your
student loans for lawyer and doctor because there's a lot of
schooling like there's there's a lot of school involved to
that yeah i can't believe people will spread misinformation
about it if you're a millennial right now tell your children
the truth is that crazy millennials now are having kids i'm
sorry millennials if you don't have a kid
Millennials are at an age that they should have kids They
should have doesn't mean they should They should have
doesn't mean you have to Sorry English is my first language
But anyway Anyway Millennials don't tell your kids That
being a lawyer or doctor is a way actually you don't have to
because because be a millennial sucks now because like we
can't afford houses and like you know fucking sucks because
you know house market housing market sucks uh uh we can
barely afford anything
So why can't you afford children?
Why the fuck will we be able to afford children's
universities?
Chat.
University is very expensive.
Like, like, millennials can barely afford their own
university tuition.
Let her, actually, they can.
They can.
That's why student loans exist.
That's why student loans fucking exist.
afford fucking student tuition.
So why the fuck would they afford the kids student tuition?
Don't tell them to be doctors or lawyers.
Tell them to go to computer science.
Tell them to get into computer science or end.
Wait, actually does engineers make a lot of money?
No.
If doctors and lawyers can't make a lot of money, so do
engineers.
Compsi!
That's the way to go!
Silicon Valley.
There we go.
We figured it out.
ComSci is the new lawyer doctor.
Computer science.
New lawyer doctor.
And Silicon Valley.
That's the goal.
It's so real.
I like that someone's like, computer science here.
It sucks.
Yes.
But you don't have to get a master's degree.
And then get a doctorate.
it.
You don't have to go to more school.
Computer science is flooded at the moment.
The thing is, okay, you're right.
Technical school.
There we go.
I figured it out, chat.
Tell your children to be plumbers and like, um, to be
plumbers and like anything else in technical school.
Trade school and trade school.
Because!
Oh.
I know I'm going to reference a South Park episode.
Because now days we can't do shit anymore like we can't we
we can't do shit anymore we always need to call somebody to
do stuff for us so now trade school is like much more
demanding because like trade school like jobs are now in
demand because no one wants to do things their own no one
knows how to do shit on their own anymore which is true
because i'm that person i need to call somebody to do stuff
like i don't know how to fucking fix feel like watch a
tutorial i still don't fucking know like i rather call
someone it's a trade school time tell your children to go
into trade school and the best part is when your child knows
how to fix the toilet or do like plumbing it'd be a handyman
you don't have to call anybody you can just be like i'm your
mom i gave birth to you fix my toilet and then like you know
with a little bit of therapy for the child after that like
you just balance it off with therapy don't don't talk to
your child like that because maybe you have to pay for your
therapy but like um so just say be like oh sweetie hey um
mom's got a leaking faucet Do you want to, do you want to
like, you know, oh man, I mean, oh, I try to call the
handyman and everything, but like, they're so backed up
right now, and it's like so expensive, son, it's so
expensive.
I just don't know what to do.
And then your son is going to be like, don't worry, mom, I
can come over and fix your, well, did I say toilet plumbing
issue?
I don't remember, whatever's fine.
I can fix your plumbing issue.
Don't spend money on that.
That's why I went to trade school.
And then, bam!
You saved money.
We did it!
We solved the issue.
I'm getting PTSD.
Look at that.
That's what you do.
I'm giving you life tips.
Guys, write this down.
I'm actually giving you life tips right now.
Tell your children to go to trade school.
Instead of doctor, lawyer.
It's not worth it.
Student loan sign.
Ria, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nia, thank you for the super chat.
ComSci is also struggling because companies overexpanded.
And now everyone's...
Oh yeah, I heard everyone's getting laid out.
off now it's much harder for new grads to get jobs i think
like that's just not comp side it's everything that's that's
definitely not just comp side it's everything everybody's
downsizing now not just comp side uh uh hey dang in the
super chat thank you thank you ducky to remind me to not pay
student list i basically get free school like hey okay okay
legally just pay for it When it's legal.
If it's legal and you have to pay for it, pay for it.
If like avoiding student loans is legal, please don't commit
illegal acts.
Thank you.
What was it?
Oh my gosh.
There was like a channel for illegal life hacks and stuff.
Oh my god.
I had a short record.
I had like a shorts channel recommended to me.
And then it was like illegal life hacks with like SpongeBob
and Patrick.
I don't know why.
It was like the channel was run by SpongeBob.
SpongeBob and and Patrick AI voices.
Did you guys see that channel?
Or am I just a freak that got recommended?
I'm just a freak.
Let's see.
Sponge illegal life hacks.
SpongeBob.
It had a lot of subscribers.
It has like almost half a million subscribers chat.
This is like, okay, this This is like the channel, the
shorts that I kept getting like, like recommended for, like
this one.
This is like, um, basically they give you like illegal life
hacks as SpongeBob Patrick AI.
I don't know why.
Oh yeah, unethical life tips.
Yeah, unethical.
Yeah, it was like unethical life tips, uh, life hacks.
And okay, like I gave an, I gave an unethical life hack.
Whereas, like, if you get summoned for Jury Duty, just,
like, convince them that you have a bi- Because, like, for
those who didn't hear this, because I said this on Twitch,
basically, like, to be in Jury Duty, you have to have zero
biases.
You have to have zero biases for, for, like, the trial.
So you shouldn't have, you should not swing over one or the
other.
Because if you have a bias, it will become a mistrial.
Because if you're like, oh, I knew it, I knew that person
was guilty the moment they walk in.
That you will give up.
You will make it a mistrial.
Even if they are guilty.
Even if they are like guilty, guilty.
You cannot admit that you have a bias towards something.
So like.
So so basically like, you know, if you get summoned to, you
know, you just be like, you know, I...
I feel...
Just be like, well, I, you know, I don't know.
I don't think that person's a bad guy, even though...
I just be like, I don't know, never met...
I don't know, he just, he seems pretty innocent, you know?
He seems pretty, seems pretty innocent.
And then, and then...
and then the judge would be like yeah we're not picking
they're not we're not picking this person to be on the jury
but that's only if you really just so just if you really
don't want to be on jury duty because you don't really want
to be in jury duty to be fair though you can't i feel like
okay okay but to be like perfectly honest if you get
somebody that doesn't want to be on jury duty on jury duty i
feel like that hurts your case more than like like more than
yeah oh sorry the lawyers do oh but you have to convince the
judge to take you uh but i just feel like if you hate jury
duty and you get into jury duty i feel like like you know it
hurts the the the trial more than helps because like they
don't want to be there like they don't want to You want
people that actually are willing to, you know, like the
justice system.
You know?
You want someone that actually likes the justice system and,
like, has zero biases.
Because what if, like, because the thing about jury duty is
that, by the way, like, if please correct me if I'm wrong,
because majority of what I know about jury duty is from TV
shows.
And just, like, really.
reading a little bit about it like just reading a little bit
so please if you're a lawyer correct me and or a judge
correct me if i'm wrong but like i'm assuming like the part
that's right was where like the jury has to be unified it
has to be like unified in their decision so i feel like you
know um if you don't want to be in jury duty and like and
the decision has to be universal?
What if I just vote for the majority?
Or unanimous, yeah.
What if I just vote for the majority because I want this to
fucking end?
Because if you don't, you like prolong the trial.
You prolong the jury duty.
So what if I just want to leave and I just vote whatever the
fuck other people were voting for?
Yeah.
So that's why I'm like um but it's different it's not true
it depends on state and the crime you can have eight out of
ten jury oh okay that's that's interesting but yeah i feel
like um i feel like uh if i didn't want to be there i would
just vote like to whatever the fuck the majority was because
i just want to leave i don't want to argue my case i was
like no if i see like evidence i was like wait a minute
maybe he is guilty but then everyone's like no he is
innocent and i was like okay
Well, I'm not going to argue about that.
I'm not going to argue why I think he's guilty.
All right, he's innocent.
All right, I'm just like, all right, I got to go home early.
Yay.
I get to go home early.
I know someone who intentionally said something offensive to
get rejected from jury duty I don't know why people bail
when they get off work for because for some people people
think jury duty is work thank you thank you I think it's
also because like jury duty is also work because like you
know like you have to go to somewhere else you don't get to
stay at home yeah you don't get you know it's not like you
can stay at home for jury duty
that's fine
yeah oh my god if you know jury notification is a concept
that exists that can get you disqualified from jury duty?
Oh my god, guys, I gave you an excuse.
Guys, you can be like, I watched a YouTuber explain jury
nullification to me.
And now I know I can have biases for jury duty.
Oh my god.
You're welcome, Chad.
I literally gave you the perfect excuse.
I literally I gave you the perfect excuse
Alright, anyway Anyway, I think I'm gonna call it here, guys
I think I'm gonna call it here I had a great time hanging
out With all of you, chat It was Your honor, are you
familiar with Tokey Bird That's about 5,000 people Out of
Jury Duty Hey, guys rest day i hope you guys enjoyed this
little bonus stream i had a uh great time hanging out with
all of you guys i had a great time hanging out with you guys
all you guys and i hope you guys had a great time chatting
with me um tomorrow is my rest day i most likely will have
my schedule out maybe uh tomorrow tomorrow most likely um
because like it's already really late and i don't really
want to post my schedule that late today so i'll work on it
today and post it for tomorrow but always.
I hope you guys had all have a great Easter.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, thank you for the Super Chat Deadpool.
Thank you.
Thanks for the stream, Doki.
It's always a pleasure.
It's always a pleasure to talk to you guys and hang out.
Bye, everybody.
Bye.